happy to see you happy to see you as
well congratulations sir now what is it
about a good old western film that folks
just love so much i think there's a
great legacy and history to the western
in american cinema there's been so many
classics you know like the oxbow
incident
um high noon with gary cooper
uh sergio leone once upon a time in the
west but i will say that this movie is a
little different yes it's the same times
the same place but it's it's dealing
more with a kind of a
thematic of characters and the human
condition that's applicable to any time
really and i think it's happening still
right now with what's going on with the
environment with trees and this is uh
pretty hard to watch because we're
dealing with the
on the near extinction of the american
buffalo so that's what this is about and
how we got there i cannot wait to see
this i can't wait to see your
transformation either because i do
believe this is the first time we are
seeing you with a shaved head in a film
so how was it saying goodbye to the lox
was it liberating were you scared yeah i
loved it i loved it oh yeah sure oh yeah
it was a good look thank you i gotta say
big congratulations to you and your wife
rico for welcoming your daughter what
just days ago how are you looking so
well-rested well
i actually had about five hours sleep in
total over five days so i was getting
one hour a night and then i came here
and i actually got
five hours last night so i think that's
what brought me back for this well your
boys are grown now are you welcoming
this new you know revisiting stage of
the infant stage of children oh
absolutely yeah the girl's dead now what
are you looking forward to most i i'm i
i want to learn you know i want to i
want to learn yeah
so fearful for the folks that could be
dating your future daughter someday yeah
well
well give me give me like a little time
she's days old
and finally i got to say i love her name
august francisca
yeah
how did you guys come up with that uh
well my father is august and my uncle is
francis and i wanted to honor both of
them so
[Music]